celebrity and politicians you know our
politicians have basically become
celebrities at this point I'm pretty
sure we've already coronated queen
Hillary which is really sad thought but
Ben Affleck now is being rumored that he
may be the next celebrity politician did
you also hear he was going to be Batman
that was a minor thing you might have
missed on Twitter but jennifer garner
his wife had a little something to say
about it right now Ben feels like he can
do more good for people politically from
outside the system would I be surprised
if one day he did go into politics no
all right that's it's a somewhat
innocuous but there there's the hint
there and people talked about Matt Damon
maybe and you know we've have a long
history of uh actors going into politics
which we'll get to in just a sec uh but
do you think this is the future that
you're gonna have to be famous first to
go into politics Ronnie did it Ronnie
pulled it off while she did and I feel
like we've been hearing this about the
bath the first so long yeah he may be
going in no he's not going in noise but
he's so interested in he might and yes
he will probably get elected to anything
that he wants cuz he I like him he's
pretty any so smart guy you know would
be the worst thing in the world but yeah
it's it's a little maybe can marry
Batman and the presidential campaign who
can Batman can you go directly from
Batman to the Senate that's the question
yeah I mean yeah you can do anything
court yet yeah the money got the right
guys behind you picked the right state
sure you could do it he's a very smart
guy I don't know whether he's you know I
don't know whether he's interested what
they forget is that you can be a smart
guy to be interested in the legislative
process uh which is you know can is dull
unless you're into it which case it's
the coolest thing you've ever been a
part of yeah something guys who were in
it have to be dedicated all these guys
we bring in our guys who literally come
in they hate the process right I hate
designing laws and they think that
that's their jobs to come there and
prevent laws and growth and progress
from happening I mean if I don't say
that they don't we know we know that's
what they made yet but do you think
that's one of the things with Obama that
he really likes campaigning and
fundraising
and speaking but he's I've heard that
he's not big on actual legislating and
getting in there and you know really
working through the bills with Congress
and what's up as opposed to someone I
Clinton who love that stuff love
striking a deal and all the new aisles
that well think would have gotten one
other thing done that brock obama has I
mean I really think that the obstinance
of the Republicans is such that would
matter mean I don't maybe a little and
that may be true about Obama but he is
uh you know he's clear the kind of
leader who'd like to sort of shape out
the the the broad parameters and then
let his guys go to work but there's no
there's no going to work in the house
that can't be done guys are playing
nicely all right let's take a look at
some of the other actors who've gone
into politics this is a tiny tiny list
Al Franken comedian he's now the senator
from Minnesota obviously Arnold
Schwarzenegger I still can't believe
that he was the governor of this state
is wild uh Ben Stein who uh you know he
was in win Ben Stein's money in East
End's and uh Ferris Bueller's Day Off
know that here's a speechwriter for
Nixon and Ford a lot of people don't
know that uh Clint Eastwood was the
mayor of Carmel California Jerry
Springer was a mayor Cincinnati until he
paid a hooker with a check that's true
Ronald Reagan obviously was a governor
of California and the president united
states and Sonny Bono was the mayor of
Palm Springs California this is just a
tiny tiny us one that's really
interesting that is not on that list is
a guy named a George Murphy who beat uh
JFK's press secretary Pierre Salinger in
California for the senate race in 1964
George Murphy was president Screen
Actors Guild from nineteen forty four
forty six Reagan was his deputy and
George Murphy was a big-time actor song
and dance man first and then became a
kind of a b-movie actor and a pretty
good one and then went to the Senate two
years before reagan went to the
governorship he was he's good-looking
dude and he was very reserved reagan
before reagan and then he went 64 insert
l7ii and then and then reagan came in 66
and went on to do a couple of laptop
yeah they go hello I knew there was a
reason that I wanted to make sure I got
it
sure I got a year right on George Murphy
finally someone fact-checking some
things we do around here that's very
nice um so one of the things I brought
up a couple of times since we've been
doing this is that I partly think that
what we need in America is not that we
need a monarchy or a royal family but I
feel like the British somehow get out
some of the juiciness of politics with
the royal family and we want our
politicians to be everything we want
them to be cool rock stars like Obama
and also nerdy policy wonks I don't know
if that's possible so is having
celebrities be politicians is that you
just make the system that much more
maybe we should just select Ben Affleck
king prince but seriously it does it
gets out a lot of because we won human
can't be all those things and if they
are the perfect rock star the most
attractive person or the most
charismatic person they're not
necessarily gonna be the best
legislatively and if somebody's an
amazing you know legislature they're not
necessarily going to be the most
charismatic Al Gore yeah um so what a I
mean I it's it's a human thing though we
want people that we recognize and we we
feel attached to already it's so much
easier uh to we want them to make
decisions for us if they're on our
ballot will vote for them yeah I think
it's a bad thing like but it's that I
think you're right as any going back
from and then you hope that when we make
the mistakes that will make that those
guys proved to be different but the idea
that ben affleck is eager and ready to
work with a 99 other guys on staying up
roll up the sleeves late at night with
staff to work out the intricacies of
certain legislation stand up to
corporate interest because there's
nobody standing up there in a general
way for you know regular people for
working Americans that they don't have a
lobby alone poor Americans I don't see
that happening and that's not a night
that's not indictment him I would want
to do it right on and also the idea that
he would immediately it's obvious that
if someone of Ben Affleck's stature and
cloud was to run but obviously you
immediately run for Senate he's not
going to go be like a congressional aide
restore a loser really in the house yeah
yeah you got that not someone like yeah
that Mouse the house this mouse um what
do you guys think so Reagan is really
the best example of this though because
he became president now everyone thinks
he's some sort of God or at least half
the people do or something like that do
the Republicans have no chance to ever
have a famous person make it anymore
because it's all the celebrities now our
Democrats or I think there's a lot that
are actually cause it Republicans yeah
you are there any who are the big
Republicans now better no better carry
oldman he's British uh Angie Harmon uh
right Angie Harmon right Angie Harmon
there's what's his name from the dating
game Chuck Woolery the big trouble is
right yeah and I don't envy them yeah yo
you talk already get sick of being in
Congress in two minutes do ya James
Woods is another one I've you guys
followed him on twitter he has become a
major right-wing yeah away yeah it's
funny James Woods is a fan of my father
through politics like through the 72
McGovern campaign so he's one of those
guys who had a transformation I guess I
didn't know that about James would ya
the other thing you hear about James
Woods may I know about that big yeah
yeah he's welcome Google you'll figure
it out that's our co-star yes that's
right by the Jimmy was I should mention
by the way this is the first time on the
reuben report that we have two people
who starred in one movie that's right
Ben and Jackie were both in white house
down did not have a scene together from
what I excited have seen with anyone
yeah yeah there was another human it was
funny because I don't you guys there are
the professional actors wrap that movie
and then we came in like eight weeks
later and not long before release that's
right in like march yet where they work
I guess in some screenings they were
like hey how's the outside world know
what's happening here we have to we will
really need the inside world to know
what's happening outside so we gotta
have some TV stuff and that was clearly
added later yeah I'd god bless him and I
was excited to see thank you yeah I had
far more lies button for more lines than
I've had in anything ever said and you
killed it
you